Welcome again to another bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎再次观看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的另一集奖励。
It's our final bonus episode before we launch season two towards the end of October.
这是我们在 10 月底推出第二季之前的最后一集奖励。
In this upcoming season, we've already got a bunch of special guests lined up and a very special announcement about our podcast, which I'm just not quite allowed to announce right now.
在即将到来的这个季节，我们已经安排了一群特邀嘉宾，并发布了关于我们播客的非常特别的公告，但我现在还不太允许宣布。
So stay tuned to the internet.
所以请继续关注互联网。
This week, we bring you an interview that I did on the new podcast, The Craft of Being, hosted by Anna Schumacher.
本周，我们为您带来我在安娜·舒马赫主持的新播客《存在的工艺》中接受的采访。
The craft of being is a podcast via a series of conversations where Anna digs into the question, what the heck even is creativity?
《存在的工艺》是一个播客，通过一系列对话，安娜深入探讨了这个问题：创造力到底是什么？
I got a chance to talk to her about producing the podcast and working with Josh and Craig and then we go into other projects I've been involved with throughout the years.
我有机会与她谈论播客的制作以及与乔什和克雷格的合作，然后我们进入了我多年来参与的其他项目。
You can listen to the craft of being wherever you get your podcasts and there's even a link in our show notes.
无论您在哪里获得播客，您都可以聆听现场的工艺，我们的节目笔记中甚至还有一个链接。
Also, fun fact, Anna's voice can be heard in the opening montage of Hymmium fan voices in the very first episode of How We Made Your Mother.
另外，有趣的是，在《我们如何造就你的母亲》第一集中，Hymmium 粉丝声音的开场蒙太奇中可以听到安娜的声音。
And now, The Craft of Being.
现在，存在的工艺。
Hi, hello, and welcome to another episode of The Craft of Being.
大家好，欢迎收看《存在的工艺》的另一集。
This is a podcast by way of a series of candid conversations where we dig into what the heck even is creativity.
这是一个通过一系列坦诚对话的播客，我们深入探讨创造力到底是什么。
Undefined yet definitive.
未定义但已确定。
We will talk about the types of of innate creative muscles that live within all of us, within you, yes, you.
我们将讨论我们所有人、你的内在创造力的类型，是的，就是你。
And we will talk about how these creative muscles evolve with us across life, work, art, and the pursuit of everything.
我们将讨论这些创造力如何在生活、工作、艺术和对一切事物的追求中与我们一起发展。
Today we're gonna chat about film and podcast media.
今天我们要讨论电影和播客媒体。
My guest today is well-versed in both, he wears many hats, and our conversation takes us through the systems that support and interact with the artistry.
今天我的客人精通这两方面，他身兼数职，我们的谈话带我们了解了支持艺术并与艺术互动的系统。
Across the board, there's this kind of double consciousness in the way artistic, creative work finds its way into the world.
总的来说，艺术、创意作品进入世界的方式存在着这种双重意识。
On one side, there's the intensity of the creative work itself, the hours of writing, rehearsing, shooting, editing, stitching together details until they finally resolve into something coherent.
一方面，创意工作本身的强度，写作、排练、拍摄、编辑、缝合细节的时间，直到它们最终分解成连贯的东西。
On the other side, there is the preparation, the scaffolding of validation, the decks, the pitches, the budgets, the endless, like me, trust me, gestures.
另一方面，还有准备工作、验证的脚手架、平台、球场、预算，还有无尽的，像我一样，相信我，手势。
You'll hear Alec talk about that, that are required before many projects can even begin.
您会听到 Alec 谈论这一点，这是许多项目开始之前所必需的。
And by begin, I mean here, begin with the goal of being seen, being picked up, becoming the thing that launches someone into a place where the work can speak for itself and that someone can keep working in this stream so far as capitalism runs the game, okay?
我所说的开始，我的意思是，从被看到、被接受的目标开始，成为将某人带入一个工作可以自己说话的地方，并且只要资本主义运行游戏，某人就可以继续在这个流中工作，好吗？
Hollywood, Hollywood, has built an empire on this double consciousness.
好莱坞，好莱坞，在这种双重意识上建立了一个帝国。
It is a city where art and commerce are bound together so tightly that they appear inseparable where the beauty of a scene and the pressure of an opening weekend are measured on the same ledger.
在这座城市，艺术和商业紧密地结合在一起，似乎密不可分，场景的美丽和开幕周末的压力都在同一个账本上衡量。
To speak about Hollywood is to speak about an entire architecture of creativity, a system that provides opportunity and exposure, and also dictates form funding and legitimacy.
谈论好莱坞就是谈论整个创造力的架构，一个提供机会和曝光度、也决定形式资金和合法性的系统。
A film is not simply the work of its director and cast.
一部电影不仅仅是导演和演员的作品。
It's also the work of financiers, distributors, marketing teams, and executives who determine and whether the work will even see the light of day.
这也是金融家、分销商、营销团队和高管的工作，他们决定这项工作是否会重见天日。
This structure is at once enabling and constraining.
这种结构既具有促进性又具有约束性。
It allows something as vast and complex as a feature film to even exist, but it also requires the artist to frame their own imagination in ways that appeal to some gatekeepers.
它允许像故事片这样庞大而复杂的东西存在，但它也要求艺术家以吸引某些看门人的方式构建自己的想象力。
The Creative Act begins long before a camera rolls, right?
创意活动早在镜头开拍之前就开始了，对吗？
It begins in the translation of vision into the pitch deck, into the log line, into a concise justification of why the work deserves to exist.
它首先将愿景转化为宣传材料、日志，以及为何该作品值得存在的简洁理由。
The podcast world has inherited many of the same dynamics.
播客世界继承了许多相同的动力。
Just like Tarantino once used to be able to make reservoir dogs in a warehouse on a whisper in a dream, so too can I sit here in our tiny spare room that quadruples as bicycle storage in my desk in a dumping space for outdoor gear and toddler toys and put my thoughts in craft out there.
就像塔伦蒂诺曾经能够在梦中低声在仓库里制作水库狗一样，我也可以坐在我们小小的备用房间里，这个房间是我桌子上自行车存放处的四倍，还有一个用于户外装备和幼儿玩具的倾倒空间，把我的想法投入到手工制作中。
Though I don't have Harvey Keitel, and thus it's just you and me.
虽然我没有哈维·凯特尔，所以只有你和我。
What might have once seemed like a freer medium, just pressed record, let the conversation flow, upload it for anyone to hear, has quickly developed its own economies of scale, its own validation structures.
曾经看似更自由的媒介，只需按下录音，让对话流畅，上传给任何人听，现在已经迅速发展出自己的规模经济和自己的验证结构。
A podcast needs a host, yes, but it also needs production schedules, advertising partnerships, distribution platforms, and metrics that prove value.
是的，播客需要主持人，但它也需要制作时间表、广告合作伙伴、分发平台和证明价值的指标。
Behind every hour of conversation released into the world are countless invisible acts of coordination, emails, calendars, edits, sponsorship copies, social media prompts.
发布到世界上的每一个小时的对话背后都有无数无形的协调行为、电子邮件、日历、编辑、赞助副本、社交媒体提示。
The work disappears into the final product and yet it is essential to the very possibility of the show.
该作品消失在最终产品中，但它对于展览的可能性至关重要。
To be clear, I am all of the roles and we do not have a sponsorship department.
需要明确的是，我负责所有角色，而且我们没有赞助部门。
There is a paradox of much of modern artistic creativity.
许多现代艺术创造力都存在悖论。
The most ephemeral media often require the most relentless scaffolding.
最短暂的媒体通常需要最无情的脚手架。
Episodes vanish into a stream, but the labor that sustains them is constant.
情节消失在溪流中，但维持它们的劳动却是持续不断的。
Movies may be remembered for decades, but before they can exist, they must pass through this obstacle course.
电影可能会被人们记住几十年，但在它们存在之前，它们必须穿过这个障碍。
In both cases for film and podcasting, the act of creation is inseparable from the structures that allow it to reach an audience.
对于电影和播客来说，创作行为都与其接触观众的结构密不可分。
There's something instructive in noticing how creators move between these systems.
留意创作者如何在这些系统之间移动是有启发性的。
Directing a film and producing a podcast may seem like entirely different crafts yet they share a common rhythm.
导演电影和制作播客似乎是完全不同的工艺，但它们有着共同的节奏。
Establish the outline, the framework, set the stage, line up the ducks, and then let the unpredictable alchemy of collaboration bring something to life.
建立轮廓、框架、搭建舞台、排列鸭子，然后让不可预测的协作炼金术将一些东西变为现实。
A director can block a scene, but the actors will always bring their own nuance.
导演可以阻止一个场景，但演员总是会带来自己的细微差别。
A producer can schedule the recording, but the conversation will always unfold in ways that no outline can fully anticipate.
制作人可以安排录制时间，但对话总是会以任何大纲都无法完全预料到的方式展开。
Creativity, as we've heard on many of these episodes, so often thrives at the junction of order and play.
正如我们在许多这样的剧集中听到的那样，创造力往往在秩序和游戏的结合处蓬勃发展。
In today's conversation, we get into the way projects are set up.
在今天的谈话中，我们将讨论项目的设置方式。
Spreadsheets, fun spreadsheets, sequences of scenes ordered and reordered, and then the joy of stepping back to watch collaborators bring the unexpected.
电子表格、有趣的电子表格、排序和重新排序的场景序列，然后退后一步观看合作者带来意想不到的乐趣。
And what emerges is the broader truth about film, television, podcasting, creativity itself, that it oscillates between the structure and flow.
出现的是关于电影、电视、播客、创造力本身的更广泛的事实，即它在结构和流程之间振荡。
Too much order, the work becomes lifeless, too much freedom, the work risks in coherence.
太多的秩序，工作就会变得毫无生气，太多的自由，工作就会面临连贯性的风险。
This is not a lament.
这不是哀叹。
It is a recognition that modern creativity is always entangled with its systems of distribution and visibility.
人们认识到，现代创造力总是与其分配和可见性系统纠缠在一起。
To make something is also to navigate the infrastructures that allow it to be seen, heard, or streamed, experienced.
制造某种东西还需要驾驭基础设施，使其能够被看到、听到、或流式传输、体验到。
here today that my guest, Alec, reflects that this negotiation is not a distraction from his creativity.
今天在这里，我的客人亚历克表示，这次谈判并没有分散他的创造力。
It is creativity.
这是创造力。
To build a schedule that makes weekly episodes possible to reorder sequences in a screenplay until they lock into place, to coordinate your collaborators.
建立一个时间表，使每周的剧集能够重新排序剧本中的序列，直到它们锁定到位，以协调您的合作者。
These are acts of invention.
这些都是发明行为。
So to hear him in his own words, without further ado, welcome to the show.
那么，话不多说，请听听他自己的话，欢迎收看节目。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Baseball.
棒球。
I'm talking about baseball.
我说的是棒球。
You've been called up.
你已经被征召了。
You're I've been taught, I'm a put me in coach, I am ready to play.
我已经接受了你们的教导，我已经被任命为教练，我已经准备好上场比赛了。
Excellent, well please introduce yourself, what's your name?
非常好，请自我介绍一下，你叫什么名字？
What do you do and how do we know each other?
你是做什么的，我们是怎么认识的？
My name is Alec Lev, I am a director and a producer, I'm going to go with that.
我的名字是亚历克·列夫，我是一名导演和制片人，我会同意这一点。
And we know each other, well we met twice, I would say at least, we in other lives definitely passed and vaguely present for me.
而且我们彼此认识，我们见过两次面，至少我会说，我们在其他生活中肯定已经过去并模糊地呈现在我面前。
We are we're sign language interpreters and we interpret it at the Marlton School for the Deaf.
我们是手语翻译员，我们在马尔顿聋人学校进行手语翻译。
I say this with I was gonna say great confidence with near confidence but it should be known that years later you through a mutual friend you hired me to direct some public service videos, I think we call them.
我说这句话的时候，我本来想说的是非常有信心，几乎有信心，但应该知道，几年后，你通过一位共同的朋友雇用我来指导一些公共服务视频，我想我们称之为。
And I don't remember exactly but the meeting probably went something like where I said, hi, nice to meet you.
我记不太清楚了，但会议的内容大概是我说的，嗨，很高兴认识你。
And you said something like you idiot, we met.
你说了类似白痴的话，我们见过面。
I think we called them tone poems at one point.
我想我们曾一度称它们为音诗。
Can you expand a little bit on what it is that you produce and or direct?
您能详细介绍一下您制作和/或导演的内容吗？
Sure.
当然。
So as we speak, I am producing the podcast How We Made Your Mother, which is a rewatch podcast of the hit television show, How We Met Your Mother.
就在我们说话的时候，我正在制作播客《我们如何创造了你的母亲》，这是热门电视节目《我们如何遇见你的母亲》的重播播客。
I can't even say the name of the show anymore.
我什至无法说出节目的名称。
How I met your mother, that's the TV show.
我是如何认识你妈妈的，那是电视节目。
And our podcast is with The Eye and How I Met Your Mother, Josh Radner, and the co-creator of the show, Craig Thomas, with whom I went to Wesleyan back in the day.
我们的播客是由《The Eye》和《老爸老妈浪漫史》的乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和该节目的联合创作者克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持的，当时我和他一起去了卫斯理学院。
so we've been great friends for decades and I worked on the show for a little bit back when it was on and so I'm producing that now and I've produced a couple of other podcasts meeting Tom Cruise, people telling insane stories about how they met Tom Cruise and as a director I have done a lot of theater I was a theater major like you I was a theater major back in college and I've done a bunch of directly mostly with deaf theaters.
所以我们几十年来一直是好朋友，我在这部剧开播的时候就工作过一段时间，所以我现在正在制作它，我还制作了几个与汤姆·克鲁斯会面的其他播客，人们讲述他们如何遇见汤姆·克鲁斯的疯狂故事，作为导演，我拍过很多戏剧，我和你一样是戏剧专业的，我在大学时也是戏剧专业的，我直接和聋人剧院做过很多表演。
I guess we can talk about that.
我想我们可以谈谈这个。
And then I directed a couple of films, one of which you produced.
然后我导演了几部电影，其中一部是你制作的。
And you and I, as of this recording, are gunning towards the next collaboration that I will direct and you will produce again.
从录音开始，你和我正在努力进行下一次合作，我将执导，你将再次制作。
Then the question I always ask everyone is, do you feel like a creative person?
那么我总是问大家的问题是，你觉得自己是一个有创造力的人吗？
I better.
我更好。
Yes.
是的。
I have no caveats to that whatsoever.
我对此没有任何警告。
Yes, that is the only thing I'm interested in doing professionally and I don't even call it professionally really.
是的，这是我唯一对专业做的事情感兴趣，但我什至不称其为专业。
It's what I want to do when I wake up and it almost doesn't matter the form that is I enjoy the act of directing the most like all the things I'm doing those few hours after so many months or years of preparation when I'm actually just there doing the directing thing that's the most fun but I love directing and producing and editing and writing and just sitting around coming up with stories so all of it yes so the caveat if there there were one is I think it would have been harder for me not that long ago to proudly declare on a podcast, I am a creator, I am an artist, that kind of thing.
这就是我醒来后想做的事情，形式几乎并不重要，我最喜欢导演的行为，就像我在经过几个月或几年的准备之后的几个小时里所做的所有事情一样，当时我实际上只是在那里做最有趣的导演事情，但我喜欢导演、制作、编辑和写作，只是坐着想故事，所以所有这些都是的，所以需要注意的是，如果有一个的话，我认为不久前对我来说会更难在播客上自豪地宣称，我是一名创造者，我是一名艺术家，诸如此类的事情。
But maybe it was passing my 50th birthday, we're like, I gotta be something.
但也许我已经过了 50 岁生日，我们就想，我必须有所作为。
And so sure, let's go with artists to create stuff, yeah.
当然，让我们和艺术家一起创作东西，是的。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Right, there's also the aspect of all of this that we talk about fairly often, which is where my friend Kit put this very well, where art and commerce are uneasy bedfellows, she said, which I love because that is always playing in the back of your mind when you are thinking how can I be the version of myself that I love the most and that I am the best for other people while also keeping the lights on to my house and feeding my children, which is I should do that, right?
是的，还有我们经常谈论的这一切的一个方面，我的朋友基特说得很好，艺术和商业是不安分的同床异梦，她说，我喜欢这一点，因为当你思考我如何才能成为我最爱的自己，我对别人最好的版本，同时又让我的房子开着灯，养活我的孩子时，这总是在你的脑海中浮现，这是我应该做的，对吗？
How do I was forgetting to do something?
我怎么忘记做某事？
Been doing it.
一直在做。
You and I and our collaborator, Josh, are working on something right now, and I think all three of us are loving every step of the way in what we're writing as an act of creation, as an act of writing.
你和我以及我们的合作者乔什现在正在做一些事情，我认为我们三个人都喜欢我们所写的每一步，作为一种创造行为，一种写作行为。
When we get together and do it, when we do it separately, I think we're enjoying that moment just in and of itself and all of course the back of our heads is Also because it means one day we'll get to make the damn thing.
当我们聚在一起做这件事时，当我们单独做这件事时，我认为我们很享受那一刻本身，当然，我们的后脑勺也是因为这意味着有一天我们会做出该死的事情。
I think our collaborative Dynamic the three of us is a good example.
我认为我们三个人的协作动态就是一个很好的例子。
What happens a lot of places in created projects or art projects where you have You figure out where each of your creative skill sets kind of lock into the larger picture For example, during our recent writer's retreat, there was the kind of messier version of like, oh, and then they should, and then they shouldn't.
在你所创建的项目或艺术项目中，很多地方会发生什么你弄清楚你的每一种创造性技能在哪里锁定在更大的图景中例如，在我们最近的作家静修期间，有一种更混乱的版本，比如，哦，然后他们应该，然后他们不应该。
And then you're there with the laptop being like, let's talk about the actual sequence number and the actual places goes, we're moving this here.
然后你拿着笔记本电脑，让我们谈谈实际的序列号和实际的位置，我们把它移到这里。
And that's where the different skill sets and interests and where people tend to like to be creative, get to come together and make something cohesive.
这就是不同技能和兴趣以及人们倾向于发挥创造力的地方，可以聚集在一起并创造出具有凝聚力的东西。
Right, though, I think I have pulled the two of you into my evil realm of enjoying those numbers also.
是的，不过，我想我已经把你们两个拉进了我也享受这些数字的邪恶领域。
I think that for both of you that's not your tendency necessarily, you're not that kind of spreadsheet head quite that I am.
我认为对于你们俩来说，这不一定是你们的倾向，你们不像我那样擅长电子表格。
We're also dealing with something so complicated structurally that it's part of it.
我们还正在处理一些结构如此复杂的事情，它是其中的一部分。
Putting them in a certain order is part of it.
将它们按一定顺序排列是其中的一部分。
But for sure, yes, we each tend towards a slightly different side of things, though there are definitely collaborations that are exciting because the collaborators work so differently.
但可以肯定的是，我们每个人都倾向于事物略有不同的一面，尽管肯定有一些令人兴奋的合作，因为合作者的工作方式如此不同。
I think we're freakishly on the same page.
我认为我们的观点惊人地一致。
I look forward to the explosion.
我期待爆炸。
I look forward to it.
我很期待。
We're just like, fuck this.
我们就像，操这个。
And someone throws a digital piece of paper down on the ground, walks away and says, this is over.
有人把一张数字纸扔在地上，走开并说，一切都结束了。
Until now, it's been lovely.
到现在为止，它一直很可爱。
I'm not looking forward to that actually at all, I don't want this at all.
我其实根本不期待这个，我根本不想要这个。
The podcast, which is available by the way, anywhere that podcasts are, I mean, anywhere that podcasts are available, you can listen to Howie Major Mother.
顺便说一句，播客可以在任何有播客的地方使用，我的意思是，任何有播客的地方，你都可以收听 Howie Major Mother 的节目。
The merch is there too, don't worry about it.
商品也在那里，不用担心。
The role of producing something like that, which has lots of moving parts, is a little bit like it's um it is kind of finding a constant order within the chaos definitely that there is someone over here doing something someone over here doing something they all don't know what the other vegetable in the soup thank you is doing and i the chef or the person eating the soup why am i doing this i am the only one that sees the whole soup stop and i like that i enjoy that i I definitely enjoy pulling all those pieces together, getting them in order, making sure that A is talking to B.
制作这样的东西，有很多活动部件，有点像在混乱中找到一个恒定的秩序，肯定有人在这里做某事，有人在这里做某事，他们都不知道汤里的其他蔬菜在做什么，谢谢你，我是厨师或吃汤的人，为什么我要这样做，我是唯一一个看到整个汤停止的人，我喜欢这一点，我绝对喜欢把所有这些碎片放在一起，让它们按顺序排列，使确定 A 正在与 B 通话。
But I also, and I guess if you were to walk into a new project that had not been yours and you had to walk into chaos and organize it, I'm down with that.
但我也认为，如果你要走进一个不属于你的新项目，而你必须走进混乱并组织它，我对此感到沮丧。
I'm a step-by-step kind of person.
我是一个按部就班的人。
Well, I'm gonna challenge you on this, sir, because the feature film that I produced nebulously produced because as I'm going to describe it, how did you produce a thing that didn't exist until it existed?
好吧，我要在这个问题上挑战你，先生，因为我制作的故事片是模糊制作的，因为正如我将要描述的那样，你是如何制作出一个在它存在之前并不存在的东西的？
But no plans this weekend was all about we're gonna go into this place with absolutely no plan and we just so happen to have a cast full of obscenely talented people who are going to kind of make this whole thing connect together.
但这个周末没有计划，我们要在完全没有计划的情况下进入这个地方，而我们恰好有一群才华横溢的人，他们会把这整件事联系在一起。
But we went into that without an idea.
但我们对此毫无想法。
And it was the structure and the dream around the chaos that was there to hold it, but everything that happened on the day was really just spaghetti, spaghetti everywhere on every wall.
正是围绕着混乱的结构和梦想支撑着它，但那天发生的一切实际上只是意大利面条，每面墙上都是意大利面条。
So we, yes, we shot a film called though plans this weekend presents Breakdown.
所以我们，是的，我们拍摄了一部名为《尽管计划本周末呈现崩溃》的电影。
And we arrived on a sound stage that had 12, 13 standing sets with a group of seven or eight actors.
我们到达了一个摄影棚，那里有 12、13 个站立布景，有七八个演员。
And we literally had no scripts, no characters, no story, absolutely zero, zero, nothing.
我们实际上没有剧本，没有角色，没有故事，绝对为零，零，什么都没有。
And we on the first day, we just got the group together, walked around and our collaborator, Josh, who we knew would be the lead.
第一天，我们把小组召集在一起，四处走动，我们的合作者乔什（Josh）我们知道他将是领导者。
I'm sorry, that is one thing that we just decided.
抱歉，这是我们刚刚决定的一件事。
Josh came up with an idea right away.
乔什立刻想出了一个主意。
We're like, Okay, pretty much said, Okay, that's the movie.
我们就像，好吧，几乎说了，好吧，这就是电影。
And then we made scene by scene and we shot behind the scenes of it.
然后我们一个场景一个场景地拍摄，并在幕后进行拍摄。
So you get to see that whole process.
所以你可以看到整个过程。
I always knew it would be a bunch of scenes that were going to tell a story and there'd be a behind the scenes aspect to it.
我一直都知道这将是一堆会讲述一个故事的场景，并且会有幕后的一面。
So very, very ordered chaos was that.
这就是非常非常有序的混乱。
And I would say that I in I love that more than anything I've ever done for sure.
我想说，我确实比我做过的任何事情都更喜欢它。
And it because actually it fits what you were talking about, which is as we know right now on the new movie, we are writing words on the page.
因为实际上它符合你所说的，正如我们现在在新电影中所知，我们正在页面上写字。
Human beings have to speak words.
人类必须说话。
We've been developing this for a couple of months and now our characters we have to just make them talk and I'm enjoying question mark the words that I'm putting down on the page to make the humans talk to each other but I also know that getting these improvisers into that room they were definitely going to come up with funnier things than I when I was writing it down so the idea of of each person in the collaboration, having their own skill that you lean on and don't think, oh, I wish I could be doing that.
我们已经开发了几个月了，现在我们的角色我们必须让他们说话，我很喜欢我在页面上写下的让人类互相交谈的文字，但我也知道让这些即兴创作者进入那个房间，他们肯定会想出比我写下来时更有趣的东西，所以每个人在合作中的想法，拥有自己的技能，你可以依靠，而不是想，哦，我希望我能做那个。
Like, I don't wish I could be doing that.
就像，我不希望我能这样做。
The people we worked with are better than me at the doing of that.
与我们一起工作的人在这方面比我做得更好。
And so again, it's very, very ordered chaos as chaos goes.
再说一次，随着混乱的发展，这是非常非常有序的混乱。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
This is why we're not writing a comedy.
这就是为什么我们不写喜剧。
Are we not?
我们不是吗？
Wait a second, we're not writing.
等一下，我们不是在写。
So he should not have the clown nose.
所以他不应该有小丑鼻子。
I didn't, I wasn't sure if I should keep the clown nose?
我没有，我不确定我是否应该保留小丑鼻子？
No.
不。
We're tossing it.
我们正在扔掉它。
The tiny car stays.
小车留下来了。
I want to walk back and talk about do you remember when in your life you first felt like creativity mattered to you what that felt like like even a sense memory of that?
我想回过头来谈谈，你还记得在你的生活中你第一次感觉到创造力对你很重要吗？那感觉就像是一种感觉记忆？
There was definitely in I want to call it kindergarten someone was making a film we were making a film and when I say film it might have even been on film.
我想称其为幼儿园，肯定有人在拍电影，我们正在拍电影，当我说电影时，它甚至可能已经在电影中了。
This was a while ago now.
这是不久前的事了。
But it was all done.
但一切都已经完成了。
It was all stop motion.
这全都是定格动画。
I think it was all stop motion of memory serves.
我认为这都是记忆的定格动画。
And I think the character I drew was like a magician.
我认为我画的角色就像一个魔术师。
So that's a deep cut there that I like to make the magic happen there.
所以这是一个很深的切口，我喜欢让魔法在那里发生。
But I do remember seeing the miracle of that.
但我确实记得看到过这个奇迹。
I don't remember thinking any other way.
我不记得有过其他想法。
There wasn't any other thing I was really interested in ever.
没有任何其他事情是我真正感兴趣的。
I liked math for a while but that wasn't like going to I wasn't gonna career myself through math and now I have my spreadsheets as a producer so I need my math but I don't remember thinking another way.
我有一段时间喜欢数学，但那不像去数学，我不会通过数学来谋求自己的职业生涯，现在我作为制作人拥有电子表格，所以我需要数学，但我不记得以另一种方式思考。
It was always making stuff and play acting and Star Wars was a huge part of it.
它总是在制作东西和表演，而《星球大战》是其中的重要组成部分。
Star Wars I was born in 1975 and so and I have a I think I have a memory of seeing Star Wars episode 4 in the theater certainly Return of the Jedi, certainly Empire Strikes Back, and then Indiana Jones, then Return of the Jedi.
星球大战 我出生于 1975 年，所以我记得在剧院看过《星球大战》第 4 集，当然是《绝地归来》，当然是《帝国反击战》，然后是印第安纳琼斯，然后是《绝地归来》。
So I was like, I was all in on movies, very, very early, they were everything.
所以我想，我非常非常早地就全身心投入到电影中，它们就是一切。
And then I started...
然后我开始...
It sounds like you're all in on Harrison Ford, specifically.
听起来你特别喜欢哈里森·福特。
A little bit on Harrison Ford.
关于哈里森·福特的一点介绍。
Witness was very big in my life.
见证人在我的生命中非常重要。
Dying young, it was very important to me as a young child.
英年早逝，对年幼的我来说非常重要。
Keep going, this is a litmus test right now.
继续吧，现在这是一个试金石。
K9 was a big one.
K9 是一个大的。
But playing with Star Wars figures was a full-time job.
但玩星球大战人物是一份全职工作。
up and making up those stories with those figures and imbuing them with personalities that weren't necessarily from the movies.
用这些人物编造故事，并赋予他们不一定来自电影的个性。
Huge part of storytelling growing up.
成长过程中讲故事的很大一部分。
You touched on before your role as a podcast producer for how we made your mother the re-watch podcast for how I'm a mother.
在你担任播客制作人之前，你谈到了我们如何让你的母亲重新观看《我是一个母亲》的播客。
There's merch, what t-shirt.
有商品，什么T恤。
But I am hoping you can expand a little bit on what the tasks and creative solutioning you do for the average life cycle of a show from making to posting.
但我希望你能稍微扩展一下你在节目从制作到发布的平均生命周期中所做的任务和创造性解决方案。
Sure.
当然。
It's a great collaboration.
这是一次很棒的合作。
I mean, ultimately, truly, and I have no reason to puff myself down.
我的意思是，最终，真的，我没有理由自吹自擂。
Can you do that?
你能做到吗？
I mean, the reason you're just gonna enjoy that is because you're gonna love listening to these two guys talk.
我的意思是，你之所以会喜欢这是因为你会喜欢听这两个人的谈话。
And we could just press record and then I could post the thing that they said.
我们可以按录音，然后我就可以发布他们所说的内容。
But I do think of each episode as a tiny little work of art and it's not a work of anything else, so it's gotta be that.
但我确实认为每一集都是一件小小的艺术品，它不是其他任何东西的作品，所以它必须是这样的。
And so it involves we planning a little bit.
因此，我们需要做一些计划。
And when I say planning, I mean scheduling, getting us all in the same place.
当我说计划时，我的意思是安排时间，让我们所有人都在同一个地方。
And that involves many phone calls and many emails and assistance and calendars and all that.
这涉及许多电话、许多电子邮件、帮助和日历等等。
And so, okay, that's the first part, not wildly thrilling, but you gotta do that.
所以，好吧，这是第一部分，不是非常令人兴奋，但你必须这样做。
You get in the same place.
你到达同一个地方。
We record ads.
我们录制广告。
We have to think about, oh, three weeks from now, I actually need this one piece.
我们必须考虑一下，哦，三周后，我实际上需要这一件。
So we're going to record this little thing now too, so you're puzzling that out as you think about a full season.
所以我们现在也要记录这个小事，所以当你思考整个赛季时，你会感到困惑。
We do, we have about 22 week season, but actually maybe 40 episodes within those weeks.
我们确实有，我们有一季大约 22 周，但实际上这几周内可能有 40 集。
And so I'm planning a little bit in advance.
所以我提前做了一些计划。
We do special episodes where people ask questions, so I have to go on to the internet and ask people questions.
我们制作特别节目，让人们提出问题，所以我必须上网问人们问题。
And there's a creative moment there where I post a little square on Instagram.
我在 Instagram 上发布了一个小方块，这是一个创意时刻。
I say, do you have any questions about such and such an episode?
我说，你对某某情节有什么疑问吗？
But then I make a little joke and a little inside joke taken from that episode.
但后来我开了一个小玩笑，还有一个取自那一集的内部玩笑。
So that's a fun bit of writing that they get to do.
所以这是他们写的一件有趣的事情。
And then, I mean, it goes on and on, and then I have to edit it, and then within the editing process, there's three different, four different programs I'm using while I'm doing it.
然后，我的意思是，它一直持续下去，然后我必须编辑它，然后在编辑过程中，我在做这件事时使用了三个不同的、四个不同的程序。
And by the way, as I feel every day, the train does not stop.
顺便说一句，正如我每天所感受到的那样，火车不会停下来。
Every Monday comes and a new episode has to happen.
每个星期一到来，都会发生新的一集。
So I'm editing an episode, planning for the next one, we're going to record, thinking about the fact that I have three others in the hopper that need to be edited and then also, oh, what about next season?
所以我正在编辑一集，计划下一集，我们要录制，考虑到我还有另外三集需要编辑，然后，哦，下一季怎么样？
I mean, there's 200 episodes of this show.
我的意思是，这个节目有200集。
There's no end to when I have to stop thinking in advance of what's gonna happen next.
当我不得不停止提前思考接下来会发生什么的时候，永无休止。
And then, you know, it's producing and like editing is such a, it disappears, right?
然后，你知道，它正在制作，就像编辑一样，它消失了，对吧？
When you listen to the podcast, I guess the hope.
当你听播客时，我猜想是希望。
I guess one says that the hope is you're not thinking about a single thing that I, Alec, have done on this show, right?
我猜有人会说，希望你不要去想我，亚历克，在这个节目中所做的任何一件事，对吗？
And it's my goal to make you not think about that.
我的目标就是让你不要去想这个。
And it's my goal to make the hosts not think about that.
我的目标是让东道主不要考虑这一点。
I just want them to have this place where they can do their best work in front of the microphone and then have that get out to the world.
我只是希望他们有一个可以在麦克风前尽自己最大努力的地方，然后将其传播到世界各地。
And so what I do disappears and the editing kind of disappears, but it's very satisfying on those Mondays when the episode is posted.
所以我所做的事情消失了，剪辑也消失了，但在周一发布这一集时，我感到非常满意。
And even though I've heard it five times by then, you pick up your phone and it's just sitting, no, it's just there.
尽管我已经听过五次了，但你拿起手机，它就在那里，不，它就在那里。
It's just one, there's no more nothing.
只剩下一个了，没有什么了。
You gotta do to it.
你必须这么做。
It's just sitting there on your phone.
它就在你的手机上。
And that's a very satisfying moment.
那是一个非常令人满意的时刻。
Yes, we have a very ephemeral job often.
是的，我们的工作经常非常短暂。
Yeah, certainly ephemeral to paint with the right word, media, medium, the stuff that I'm doing, the stuff that you're doing here, that we're clicking away just constantly is not the work, is not the physical work of art that anyone's looking at kind of sort of.
是的，用正确的词、媒体、媒介进行绘画当然是短暂的，我正在做的东西，你在这里做的东西，我们不断点击的东西不是作品，不是任何人都在看的那种实体艺术作品。
It totally is and it totally is it.
完全是这样，完全是这样。
Right, there's that difference between the art of the making, you know, it's all the chips of marble on the floor versus the statue of David which you actually see at the end.
是的，制作艺术之间存在着差异，你知道，地板上的所有大理石碎片与你最终看到的大卫雕像。
And you don't look at the sculpture and think about the rectangle it used to be.
而且你不会看着雕塑并想到它曾经是矩形的。
Right.
正确的。
You know, that kind of thing.
你知道，那种事。
You know, he also has, I'm gonna get myself in trouble of telling you to talk about art at all, but he's also got those statues of the figures that are still coming out of the stone.
你知道，他也有，我会让自己陷入麻烦来告诉你谈论艺术，但他也有那些仍然从石头里出来的人物雕像。
It's in the same museum as David.
它和大卫在同一个博物馆。
And I totally took to those.
我完全接受了这些。
And now thinking about like what I do with my life dolly making stuff, but I also am a constant stream of making behind the scenes stuff of the stuff I'm making, because I'm fascinated by that.
现在想想我用我的生活做的娃娃制作东西，但我也不断地在幕后制作我正在制作的东西，因为我对此很着迷。
And so the idea that I like that I saw those 20 years ago, I'm now putting this together.
所以我喜欢 20 年前看到的想法，现在我把它们放在一起。
I like the statues leaving the marble, because I like the behind the scenes of it.
我喜欢离开大理石的雕像，因为我喜欢它的幕后花絮。
I get to still see that.
我仍然看到这一点。
That's interesting.
那很有意思。
How do you know when something that you're making is done, or if it's resisting being done?
你怎么知道你正在做的事情何时完成，或者是否拒绝完成？
It's a great moment.
这是一个伟大的时刻。
You do need to decide that it's done.
你确实需要决定它已经完成。
I mean, I guess one doesn't.
我的意思是，我猜有人不这么认为。
And it's, you know, you listen, read stories and we're on Try Now's book on Da Vinci to read about the Mona Lisa of like 15 years of painting over and over and over and over and over but then he stopped at some point and so I guess no you don't ever have to have to stop there's a church in New York on 110th Street it's part of the mission is that it's never done and so it is always being it is always being remodeled in some way refurbished in some way but I love it I love when you're editing.
你知道，你听，读故事，我们在《现在就尝试》关于达芬奇的书中读到了关于《蒙娜丽莎》的故事，他花了 15 年的时间一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地画画，但后来他在某个时候停了下来，所以我想不，你不必停下来，在纽约 110 街有一座教堂，它的使命的一部分是它从未完成，所以它总是存在，它总是在被改造以某种方式翻新，但我喜欢它，我喜欢你编辑的时候。
And so let's say that two people have said something.
假设有两个人说了些什么。
Person A says something, person B says something.
A 说某事，B 说某事。
But at the end of person A's sentence, there's some gibberish, something garbled, and you can't use that.
但是A的句子末尾有一些乱码，一些乱码，你不能使用它。
So you have to edit that out.
所以你必须把它编辑掉。
Now you have to make it sound like these two people spoke to each other.
现在你必须让它听起来像是这两个人在互相交谈。
But the part in the middle where the actual overlap is gone.
但中间实际重叠的部分消失了。
So now I need to make a new overlap.
所以现在我需要进行新的重叠。
I need to make it sound like this conversation happen that way or just any edit in a movie someone's running in this direction then you cut to the next shot.
我需要让它听起来像是这次对话以这种方式发生，或者只是电影中某人朝这个方向运行的任何剪辑，然后你切到下一个镜头。
There's something when you when you make that edit happen you get those two clips next to each other and you figure out where one should end and one should stop and I might be right I might be wrong someone else might do it a different way but I definitely have a moment where I go that's exactly the way it should be that's it yeah I'm not changing and and when you're editing you're dealing with as little as one 24th of a frame and And there is a difference between moving it here or moving it one 24th of a frame over there and there's just something in me that goes I am done with this moment, which is not how I feel necessarily about writing words on a page that especially dialogue To that have you ever felt like a Project or a task is really More like making itself and you're kind of along for the ride or do you usually feel like you're definitely molding The thing yeah, I don't I've heard a lot of writers certainly talk about that the characters are sort of starting to speak For themselves and you're a bit along for the right.
当你进行编辑时，你会看到这两个剪辑彼此相邻，你会弄清楚一个应该在哪里结束，一个应该在哪里停止，我可能是对的，我可能是错的，其他人可能会以不同的方式做，但我肯定有一个时刻，我应该这样做，就是这样，是的，我不会改变，当你编辑时，你要处理的只有一帧的二十四分之一，而且将其移至此处或将其移至一帧之间是有区别的那边一帧的第 24 帧，我心里有一些东西，我已经完成了这一刻，这不是我在一页上写文字的感觉，尤其是对话，你是否曾经觉得一个项目或一项任务真的更像是在制作自己，你是一种顺风顺水的感觉，或者你通常觉得你肯定在塑造东西是的，我没有，我确实听到很多作家谈论角色开始为自己说话，你有点向右走。
I guess I'm just I'm not that mystical a fella And I don't really see things that way.
我想我只是一个没那么神秘的家伙而且我并不真的那样看待事情。
I'm open to it being that way But no, I do feel like I'm I'm pulling a pulling or pushing when I'm making something or when we are making something, we the collective, we are literally you and me and our other collaborators, I feel like it's us doing the thing, making the thing.
我对此持开放态度，但不，我确实觉得当我在做某事或当我们在做某事时，我在拉或推，我们是集体，我们实际上是你和我以及我们的其他合作者，我觉得是我们在做这件事，创造这件事。
But I think I get into that flow pretty quickly because I'm so desirous of starting, of working.
但我认为我很快就进入了这种状态，因为我非常渴望开始工作。
I mean, when we hang up, I'm gonna jump back into something or other.
我的意思是，当我们挂断电话后，我会跳回某件事或那件事。
Let's wrap this up.
让我们总结一下吧。
I'm not, I'm not, we have work to do.
我不是，我不是，我们还有工作要做。
Yes, as do I, yes, but I do think that getting to that state where you're really just in it comes swiftly and comes beautifully because the other things have been set up in such a way in an intelligent and capable way because you have done this for a long time, you actually and the real you have done this for a long time, whatever your thing is, and then you can gift yourself the chance to really just swim around.
是的，就像我一样，是的，但我确实认为，进入那种你真正处于其中的状态来得很快，而且来得很漂亮，因为其他的事情已经以一种聪明而有能力的方式以这种方式建立起来，因为你已经这样做了很长时间，你实际上和真正的你已经这样做了很长时间，无论你的事情是什么，然后你可以给自己一个真正游泳的机会。
Right.
正确的。
And so to that, I think there's kind of the two sides of art making or thing doing.
因此，我认为艺术创作或做事有两个方面。
How do you like that?
你觉得怎么样？
Where it's...
它在哪里...
It was at the Alteredame of this podcast.
这是在这个播客的 Alteredame 上。
Yes, I do.
是的，我愿意。
I'm on a shield marker is thing doing.
我在盾牌上标记正在做的事情。
Just, it's actually the craft of thing doing.
只是，这实际上是做事的技巧。
It's still, and that part of anyone's creative process or use of those muscles can be more structural and some can be more loosey goosey and they can go exist.
它仍然是，任何人的创作过程或对这些肌肉的使用的一部分可以更加结构化，有些可以更加松散，而且它们可以存在。
I think they completely coexist.
我认为它们完全共存。
You will remember that there was a scene we were doing during our California Connect where we were doing these short videos with these communication devices, where the scene took place in a theater, we were shooting in a theater, and the idea was that rehearsals for a show were going on.
你会记得我们在加州连接期间做了一个场景，我们用这些通信设备制作这些短视频，场景发生在剧院里，我们在剧院里拍摄，想法是正在进行一场演出的排练。
And there of course was no show, we were just approximating, we were saying, okay, we're doing Midsummer Night's Dream, but of course we didn't stage Midsummer Night's Dream at all.
当然没有演出，我们只是近似，我们说，好吧，我们正在做《仲夏夜之梦》，但当然我们根本没有上演《仲夏夜之梦》。
So there were three or four actors on stage, hour actors who were then playing actors who were characters in the show.
所以舞台上有三四个演员，小时演员然后扮演剧中角色的演员。
We like stuff like this.
我们喜欢这样的东西。
And so I'm directing this and it's, we're going to basically just, all I need is a lot of shots of it looking like you're rehearsing a show, but you're not.
所以我正在导演这个，我们基本上只是，我所需要的只是很多看起来你正在排练节目的镜头，但你不是。
You don't know where to go.
你不知道该去哪里。
And I just wasn't going to block.
我只是不想阻止。
I wasn't going to sit there and take an hour to go, okay, you walk here, you walk here, work it out.
我不会坐在那里花一个小时去，好吧，你走到这里，你走到这里，解决这个问题。
Add to the fascination here is our director photography, our mutual friend, Ruan, who is deaf, he was on the camera, he was operating the camera.
这里更令人着迷的是我们的摄影导演，我们共同的朋友阮，他是聋子，他在镜头前，他在操作相机。
And he and I planned absolutely zero whatsoever.
他和我的计划绝对为零。
And so what we do is we just let the camera run for 10 minutes.
所以我们所做的就是让相机运行 10 分钟。
And he and I are running around like lunatics.
我和他像疯子一样到处乱跑。
I believe you actually were interpreting in the moment for him.
我相信你当时实际上正在为他翻译。
But I don't even know that he was watching much of what you were doing.
但我什至不知道他在观察你所做的很多事情。
We were I was just screaming out to the actors.
我们只是对演员们大喊大叫。
Okay.
好的。
Of course, I don't remember anyone's name now or then, but we'll call them John.
当然，我现在或那时都不记得任何人的名字，但我们会称他们为约翰。
John, you walk down left.
约翰，你向左走。
Okay, now crossover and her now she said, and it's like, okay, I use my theater, my theater director brain to be staging a play while guiding a camera to come over here and go over there.
好吧，现在交叉，她现在说，就像，好吧，我用我的剧院，我的剧院导演的大脑来上演一场戏剧，同时引导摄像机从这里到那里。
And that was using all those, all the things all at once in a distinctly ordered, a distinctly ordered chaos.
那就是在一个明确有序的、一个明确有序的混乱中同时使用所有这些、所有的东西。
I do remember that.
我确实记得这一点。
I was interpreting, but what's, what stood out to me then, and I remember now and I'm reminded in this moment, is that Ruan also seemed to instinctively go where things needed to go.
我在解释，但当时对我来说最突出的是，我现在还记得，这一刻我想起，阮似乎也本能地走到了需要去的地方。
I was certainly not facilitating the communication really at all.
我当然根本没有真正促进沟通。
And I think that speaks to both of you having a really strong, it's kind of like an eye for storytelling and the movement.
我认为这说明你们俩都有很强的能力，就像讲故事和动作的眼睛一样。
Like you both understood from communicating about it and some generally beforehand, we need to capture the feeling of this space, the movement of this space and these people.
就像你们通过沟通和事先的一些普遍了解一样，我们需要捕捉这个空间的感觉、这个空间和这些人的运动。
It needs to feel like this.
它需要这样的感觉。
and then you just made it happen.
然后你就让它发生了。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I'm both a planner, clearly, definitely.
显然，我既是一名计划者，又是一名计划者。
My spreadsheets have spreadsheets, but I think what I want to do is plan all the way up to a certain moment and then let the plan trust that the scaffolding is there, the structures.
我的电子表格有电子表格，但我认为我想做的是一直计划到某个时刻，然后让计划相信脚手架就在那里，结构就在那里。
where everyone also has the skills to perform in the moment.
每个人都拥有当下表现的技能。
And then the fun part is the question marks, right?
然后有趣的部分是问号，对吧？
It's not as much fun to say, okay, now you specifically, I want you to take four steps over there.
说“好吧，现在具体来说，我希望你往那边走四步”并不那么有趣。
I mean, you could work that way.
我的意思是，你可以这样工作。
And that's why no plans this weekend.
这就是为什么这个周末没有计划。
And the podcast too is just less, okay, I got it, the stage is set.
播客也少了，好吧，我明白了，舞台已经搭建好了。
I have set the stage for y'all.
我已经为大家搭好了舞台。
And then do your thing.
然后做你的事。
whether it's Josh or Craig doing their thing for an hour or a bunch of actors doing something in front of a camera for a couple of minutes, that's a joy for me is the stuff I could not possibly have planned and I just get to sit back and watch it.
无论是乔什或克雷格做他们的事情一个小时，还是一群演员在镜头前做几分钟的事情，这对我来说是一种乐趣，因为这些事情是我不可能计划好的，我只是坐下来观看它。
Yeah.
是的。
This comes up so often with people that I talk to about the way that they have retooled what is a more freeform creative self into a more career-based creative self, that there is the same word comes out.
人们经常提到这个问题，以至于我和他们谈论如何将更自由的创造性自我转变为更加基于职业的创造性自我，结果出现了同一个词。
There's this scaffolding in place, there's some structure in place because when you have that there, then you can have also the more play part where you could be a little bit more experimental in what you're doing and you say, ah, that doesn't really work, but it's okay because you have all the shelves of other options there.
有这个脚手架，有一些结构，因为当你有了它，那么你也可以有更多的游戏部分，你可以在你正在做的事情上进行更多的实验，然后你说，啊，这并没有真正起作用，但没关系，因为你那里有所有其他选择的架子。
And there is also a certain self-trust necessary to say, I built a good skeleton here.
还有一定的自信心是必要的，我在这里建立了一个很好的骨架。
Great.
伟大的。
Now we can kind of dress it up and that's applicable in so many different creative paths, career paths.
现在我们可以对它进行一些修饰，这适用于许多不同的创意道路、职业道路。
It's also very sad.
也是非常难过的。
You know, it's like a soup on the house.
你知道，这就像家里的汤。
You know, for no plans, we really just shot what was there.
你知道，因为没有计划，我们只是拍摄了那里的东西。
Yes, you did not have a huge amount to do.
是的，你没有太多事情要做。
In fact, you were planning I believe our next thing while you were sitting in the kitchen tapping away, but for the California Connect stuff, the beauty also for a director is to have a producer like you, where things appear.
事实上，当你坐在厨房里敲敲打打的时候，你就在计划我们的下一件事，但对于《加州连接》的东西来说，对于导演来说，美丽的地方也在于有一个像你这样的制片人，事情出现在那里。
It's so cool that you've made these plans, but as the director, I don't bring stuff anywhere.
你制定了这些计划真是太酷了，但作为导演，我不会把东西带到任何地方。
I just blissfully show up, and when they're there, that's an incredibly inspiring creative moment that the tools you think you wanted were put there by someone that has the skills to put them there.
我只是高兴地出现，当他们在那里时，那是一个令人难以置信的鼓舞人心的创意时刻，你认为你想要的工具被有能力把它们放在那里的人放在那里。
And now I get to move them around, and someone else gets to play in front of them too.
现在我可以移动它们，其他人也可以在它们面前玩耍。
How would you describe, in your own words, the difference in is not exactly what I mean to say.
您如何描述，用您自己的话来说，差异并不完全是我的意思。
I can only be me.
我只能是我。
How would you describe the difference in creativity and art in your own experience of a relationship to either of those things being not mutually exclusive?
根据您自己的经验，您如何描述创造力和艺术与这两者之间并不相互排斥的关系的差异？
Sure.
当然。
I got it.
我得到了它。
I got this one.
我得到了这个。
I think creativity is putting something new into the world.
我认为创造力就是给世界带来新的东西。
That's That's all, folks.
就这些了，伙计们。
We'll see you later.
我们稍后再见。
Thanks, podcast.
谢谢，播客。
That's the end, season one.
第一季就这样结束了。
We've solved it.
我们已经解决了。
The craft of thing-doing.
做事的技巧。
Season one.
第一季。
The craft of thing-doing is place of meaning to the world.
做事的技巧对世界来说是有意义的。
It is.
这是。
And I guess that the, what I would suggest as not being art but being creative is any task you have at your job, say you're waiting tables and you do it a certain way.
我想，我建议的不是艺术而是创造力，是指你在工作中遇到的任何任务，比如说你在服务员，你以某种方式来做。
And then you realize, oh, if I walk around this table that way, or if I'm literally collecting the plates, I should stack it this way.
然后你意识到，哦，如果我那样绕着桌子走，或者如果我真的在收集盘子，我应该这样堆放。
That hasn't been done before, or this hasn't been done before by you, who cares if someone else has done it.
这以前没有做过，或者你以前没有做过，谁在乎别人是否做过。
It hasn't been done before you.
在你之前还没有人做过。
So you've created a solution.
所以您已经创建了一个解决方案。
You've created a plan.
你已经制定了一个计划。
You have not just listened to what someone told you to do.
你不只是听从别人告诉你要做的事。
You haven't just copied what someone told you to do.
你不只是复制别人告诉你做的事情。
You have made something new.
你做了一些新的事情。
But I think art, a piece of art has a kind of unity to it, to all of its parts are telling the same story or all of its parts are actively telling disparate stories, if that is the story you want to tell.
但我认为艺术，一件艺术品有一种统一性，它的所有部分都在讲述同一个故事，或者它的所有部分都在积极地讲述不同的故事，如果这就是你想讲述的故事。
But there is a big spiritual, philosophical, temporal, beginning, middle, and end to your work of art that you have created as compared to a solution, a spreadsheet, a path taken, a way to sell something, a way to walk, a way to think that is creating, but not art.
但是，与解决方案、电子表格、所采取的路径、销售某种东西的方式、行走方式、思考方式相比，你所创造的艺术作品有一个大的精神、哲学、时间、开始、中间和结束，这是创造，但不是艺术。
Yes.
是的。
Good.
好的。
I do.
我愿意。
Yeah.
是的。
How'd I do?
我怎么样？
You do.
你做。
Great.
伟大的。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Do I get to get to clip that on the internet?
我可以在互联网上剪辑它吗？
Is that on the internet?
是在互联网上吗？
It will be.
这将是。
Yes.
是的。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I think about these differences all the time and where that line is and how to describe the the conversation that a work of art might be trying to suggest to the world by being viewed or consumed in some way versus the creative solution of a logistical profession or even a spreadsheet there's I I work with someone now who I will say I need these nine things to be possible in a sheet and he'll go okay and he'll create formulas where it's all speaking to each other and I just go, wow, that's awesome.
我一直在思考这些差异，以及那条线在哪里，以及如何描述一件艺术品可能试图通过某种方式被观看或消费而向世界暗示的对话，与物流专业甚至电子表格的创造性解决方案相比，我现在和一个人一起工作，我会说我需要在一张纸中实现这九件事，他会没事的，他会创建公式，让所有东西互相交流，我只是说，哇，太棒了。
Is there a creative skill set that you don't have but you are interested in learning or growing more in?
是否存在您不具备但有兴趣学习或进一步发展的创意技能？
I would say that directly related to the work I do, I made a film called What, which is a silent film with deaf actors and I really did it, especially I could in borrowing from a tradition of silent black and white films that pretty much use master shots, just wide shots of people in the frame.
我想说的是，与我所做的工作直接相关的是，我拍了一部叫《什么》的电影，这是一部由聋人演员主演的无声电影，我确实做到了，特别是我可以借鉴黑白无声电影的传统，这些电影几乎使用主镜头，只是画面中人物的广角镜头。
They're performing on stage for you in the cameras there to show you that.
他们在舞台上通过摄像机为您表演，向您展示这一点。
Then the next one when we did no plans this weekend, there's some cinematic choices made there but we're really trying to just capture the comedians saying the things and still that was pretty much wide shots of people talking.
然后下一场，当我们这个周末没有计划时，那里做出了一些电影选择，但我们真的试图捕捉喜剧演员所说的事情，但那仍然是人们说话的广角镜头。
Like we didn't really do a a lot of not that many close-ups here they are.
就像我们并没有真正拍很多特写镜头一样。
We really do that many close-ups, but we did some here and there.
我们确实拍了很多特写镜头，但我们还是到处拍一些。
I would say that this next one what we want to do, I want it to be nothing less than the most beautiful movie ever made.
我想说，下一部我们想做的，我希望它成为有史以来最美丽的电影。
So I'm gonna have some work to get done between now and there.
所以从现在到那时我还有一些工作要做。
You're aiming to keep now and then drop off.
你的目标是现在保留然后放弃。
Okay.
好的。
Great.
伟大的。
So that that's something is really ingesting some movies in the style, ingesting some art in the style that opens my brain up a little more to how to use that camera, to tell a beautiful story beautifully.
所以这确实是在吸收一些电影的风格，吸收一些艺术的风格，让我的大脑更多地了解如何使用相机，美丽地讲述一个美丽的故事。
Well, I'm rooting for you.
好吧，我支持你。
I think so.
我想是的。
Great.
伟大的。
This has been great.
这太棒了。
Thank you for talking to me about this and all the things that you do.
感谢您与我谈论这件事以及您所做的所有事情。
And all of the, I'm really, I admire the fact that you are able to so freely go between a lot of order and structure into allowing yourself to enjoy that for yourself in all the fun ways.
所有这些，我真的，我很钦佩这样一个事实：你能够如此自由地在许多秩序和结构之间切换，让自己以所有有趣的方式享受它。
And then before we go, you might as well tell us for the third time what you're up to, where we can find it and how we can support the show.
然后在我们离开之前，您不妨第三次告诉我们您在做什么、我们在哪里可以找到它以及我们如何支持这个节目。
the show.
演出。
Sure.
当然。
How we made your mother is available everywhere.
我们如何塑造你的母亲随处可见。
Super fun podcast.
超级有趣的播客。
If you're a fan of how I met your mother, start watching again and listen along with us.
如果您喜欢我是如何认识您母亲的，请重新开始观看并与我们一起聆听。
If you've never seen it, this is your time to get started.
如果您从未见过它，那么现在是您开始的时候了。
Start from the beginning and we are going episode by episode.
从头开始，我们将逐集进行。
And the show is not quite a scene by scene breakdown.
而且这部剧并不是一个场景一个场景地分解。
It's kind of a what is this episode talking about and Josh and Craig made this in their 30s and now they're in their early 50s and they're thinking about life very differently and art very differently and thinking about what they made back then in a new way and so I think it's exciting to listen to for that reason and how we majormother.com it's all right there.
这集讲的是什么，乔什和克雷格在 30 多岁的时候制作了这个，现在他们已经 50 多岁了，他们对生活和艺术的思考方式非常不同，并且以一种新的方式思考他们当时所做的事情，所以我认为听到这个原因以及我们 Majormother.com 的表现是令人兴奋的。
Check out what WHAT question mark is on all the things.
看看所有东西上的问号是什么。
I think I think you can get it on, you buy it from Apple and watch it in various places, I don't actually know, Amazon, something like that.
我想我认为你可以得到它，你从苹果购买它并在不同的地方观看它，我实际上不知道，亚马逊，类似的东西。
And then we'll just stay tuned, just stay tuned for what comes next.
然后我们将继续关注，继续关注接下来会发生什么。
All right, well we'll do this again after we make our next movie.
好吧，我们拍下一部电影后会再做一次。
Just keep running credits and things for people to keep their eye on.
只要继续运行积分和其他东西以供人们关注即可。
Excellent.
出色的。
The craft of being is produced and hosted by me.
存在的工艺是由我制作和主持的。
Music is wide-eyed by Colin O'Brien Lux.
科林·奥布莱恩·勒克斯 (Colin O'Brien Lux) 的音乐令人惊叹不已。
Big thanks as always to my dogs for barking through these six minutes of every single recording session, definitely check out the show notes for Collins Bandcamp, more about today's guest, their links and socials and anything else we mentioned on the show, and if you want to get in touch, come find me on Instagram at The Craft of Being, or send me an email at thecraftofbeingpod at gmail.com.
一如既往地非常感谢我的狗在每次录音的这六分钟里吠叫，一定要查看 Collins Bandcamp 的演出笔记，更多关于今天的嘉宾、他们的链接和社交以及我们在节目中提到的任何其他内容，如果你想联系我，请在 Instagram 上的 The Craft of Being 上找到我，或者在 gmail.com 上的 thecraftofbeingpod 上给我发电子邮件。
Thanks for being here and until next time.
感谢您来到这里，直到下次。